all right eden
yeah you didn't know where'd you grow up
where are you from originally uh i'm
from orlando florida orlando yeah i grew
up more in like
i moved around a lot actually
um
but i'm
i'm from the hood pretty much i'm from
pine hills vodka area
but i've moved around a lot when i was a
kid i went to like 12 schools
literally yeah tell me about your family
so i grew up with my mother
my father left when i was like four
[ __ ]
but my mother she when i grew up with
her she was sick my mother has ms so
i grew up with a mother who like pretty
much kind of work can walk
i have two older brothers
and so that was kind of hard growing up
with them too
i dealt with a lot of [ __ ] like just you
know being out in the streets and
abuse and all types of things like
some people go through [ __ ] like that
and that's okay you know what i mean but
like it made me strong what kind of
abuse did you think so you know i dealt
with a lot of physical abuse mental
like my mother was also bipolar
growing up so it was a lot to deal with
you finished high school yeah i actually
did i got two diplomas i went to a
performing arts school
for my junior and senior year butler
tech when i lived in ohio at the time i
lived up there for four years
so i made an effort to finish that even
though we were like in a pandemic and
everything but i graduated in 2020
so so you're how old now
i'm 20. 20. yeah i know my birthday was
literally like
a month ago
so and you've been dancing since when
since as soon as i turned 18 like the
week of like my father kicked me out
when i was like eight straight 18 really
abusive
went through a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] with
him and honestly like
dancing saved me like
yeah i used to always like watch youtube
videos like mine
and like stuff and
it made me like want to be a dancer
because like i knew the financial
freedom that came with it and since i
was already in dancing i figured like
it'd be work out for me
and honestly i've been out here in these
streets vanessa and i'm not even gonna
lie like since i was a kid so it's like
i just knew how to work with people i
guess and it just worked out for me and
the lifestyle you'd be
living if you had a square job at a
department store or grocery store or
something like that restaurant
would not afford you the lifestyle you
have today
oh you're saying if i had a job like
that i couldn't have the life no
no
i got tired of being broke
and honestly like dancing's quick money
so it's like when you start getting
money and you never have money you spend
a lot of money
and so i had to work on that habit too
you have a spending problem too
i love to spend money and being an
artist too like you know i have to
invest into myself so i don't feel like
it's ever bad to just go shopping like i
deserve it and i work hard
and i'm a strong independent woman and
why not like you know you gotta splurge
for yourself so tell me about your
experience working at the club
man it's it's just mixed
especially being black you deal with a
lot of racism i'm not even gonna lie
like i've been fired from clubs just for
being black like and i make a lot of
money too like so
but the [ __ ] that i go through like i've
met a lot of celebrities and like they
always want like the like lighter girls
to go inside the rooms and represent the
club but
for some reason i just attract
like i just attract
meeting people like that i guess
it's all about energy and tell me about
the guys that are your clients customers
the customers
see like at first it was like
i hated it they were rude disrespectful
but once i really learned my power
like
i give off vibes like don't [ __ ] with me
and i demand respect and
being as beautiful as i am and how i
carry myself
i think people respect me so you're in
the power position in the club yeah when
you come in there it's my world and you
do what i say and you give me what i
want or i don't give a [ __ ] and i'm
leaving like the [ __ ]
somebody else is gonna do it for me so
you can either do it or you can watch
somebody else get what you want like
it's that simple we're not fun to play
games it's purely the money for you yeah
period
fairly money have you ever met a guy
that you liked in the club yeah i have
i haven't seen it's possible yeah it's
possible
yeah
it's possible to be with somebody that's
from the club it just depends the person
so then you make how much a night you
think on average it depends it depends i
would say like
on a bad night
like 500
so
but like it just depends on where you go
you know what i mean like i don't really
um but it's
you working we're in tampa right now but
you work in other cities yeah um i like
to work in like miami palm beach i've
worked in atlanta
i've worked all over i've worked in
chicago
um
i haven't worked in vegas yet i want to
go work in vegas but you have to be 21
to go to vegas what have you learned
about men from doing this kind of work
i learned that
because growing up i had like daddy
issues and stuff like that because like
i didn't get like the love and attention
i deserved
and like being treated the way i was
treated i felt like i deserved to be
treated that way
but i didn't and so
honestly i learned
i don't really give a [ __ ] about what a
[ __ ] think about me like i'm sorry like
men they they just
don't if they don't want you they'll
want somebody else it's just like who
cares like you know what i mean like
that's not validation for who you are
like at all like and same thing for
everybody else like male and female but
just like especially men like girl
you know how easy it is to get a man you
can get any man you want like
period
so that's how i think about it
and if you don't [ __ ] with me that just
means
you got a weird taste but is there any
are there any negative
repercussions from living this
doing this kind of work oh my gosh the
toll it takes on your [ __ ] body and
it's mentally draining like
i've had like days where i just broke
down and i was like i'm [ __ ] tired of
doing this [ __ ]
like it's really tiring but tell me
about the physical part first
like [ __ ]
it's hard work i've been dancing for a
long time so it's not as bad on me but
like i've seen girls with like bruises
all up and down their legs
and
honestly like you always have to go get
your back done you're like it's just
it's a lot to take care of you always
have to have your toes done like because
it takes damage on your toes you always
mess up your polish or something
always breaking a nail it's just like
you always got to have the false
eyelashes and all that stuff
i mean i don't have to but you know like
i like to put on what
i feel like makes me feel like a bomb
[ __ ] and if i feel like lashes make me
feel like that [ __ ] then i'ma wear
lashes like but i don't need to wear
lashes there's days i wasn't wearing
lashes and i still made bags so there's
days i've worn on clothes
normal clothes and i still made bread so
it's like
it's really not even it's just like a
vibe thing for me more like
real cereal and tell me about the
emotional
toll it takes
i'm not even gonna lie like going down
to miami
some hood clubs like i like to go to
more mixed clubs because like
it's a good little mix you know you get
a little bit of everything
but them hug clubs all the [ __ ] are
thick as [ __ ] i'm not even gonna lie
like something
and like
there's like nights where like i've gone
to a club with all thick [ __ ] and i
didn't make a single [ __ ] dollar
because you will have nights like that
and honestly it's just like
i can see how some girls like want to
get enhancements because like it makes
you feel shitty
like not wanted but like i know i'm that
[ __ ] so if you're not [ __ ] with me
it's just because you want
you want somebody who
i guess is a different type that's what
makes it work around
you might want a different type but if
you really got to speak to me and felt
my energy then but not everybody's going
up in there for that some people just
want big booty [ __ ] and that's okay
like so does this work build up your
self-esteem ultimately or knock it down
build my self-esteem for sure
for sure
i don't give a [ __ ] i never gave a [ __ ]
about how people really felt about me so
i'm very confident yes because
confidence is everything if you take
anything from this confidence is the key
to life if you don't believe in yourself
nobody else will if you hold yourself
like you're that [ __ ]
they're gonna think you're that [ __ ]
too and even if that shit's fake they
don't know the difference and that's the
real truth
oh yeah for sure
and then eventually just get there you
know but
what does your family think of you doing
this oh yeah
[Laughter]
that's funny um
so my family
that's funny you asked because i grew up
seventh day of venice so like that's
like christian
and
i told my mother because my mother
actually when she passed away like i had
told her previously that i want to be a
dancer and she was like go right ahead
says like and then my other aunt like
she has like a doctor's degree and
everything
and she just was kind of telling me like
i feel like my family
the women in my family
they've all really been through [ __ ]
because of what men have put them
through
and so they encouraged me to do whatever
makes me happy
and if as long as i don't have student
loans like they they're like we're happy
so
you know as long as i'm safe that's all
that matters to them so
what is your
it doesn't sound like you're looking to
get out what would your goal be for the
next five ten years i'm definitely
trying to get the [ __ ] out like as soon
as possible
yeah um
uh i actually have a music video that i
have coming up this month and i'm
planning on dropping a lot of music that
i have on my youtube channel and i'm on
all platforms so go check me out y'all
i'll leave that down below
but um yeah i definitely want to take
off with my music like that's my number
one priority right now like i know what
my purpose is and i i definitely want to
expand into a lot of things and like
help younger people and youth and
troubled youth and people like me you
know like because i've been through a
lot of [ __ ] and i relate to people and i
feel like if i can get to where i want
to be then i can inspire other people
that if even if you have like a tough
background
you can still be that [ __ ] do you feel
like you if you had a dad that was in
your life
for your whole childhood that might have
your situation could be different yeah
yeah but my father he's narcissistic and
honestly i genuinely feel like
a good dad yes but my father if he was
part of my life when i was growing up
i'd be more [ __ ] up than i even was
straight up because he was just like he
treated me like [ __ ] like the abuse and
the things that i've went through
and the isolation and the lies and you
know the [ __ ] that even when my mother
died like the [ __ ] talking that he would
say to me and just like
i don't know anybody who's more eviler
than him so i really feel like i came
out better because i wasn't there and
had him but i did have i do have a
stepdad
and he came into my life around
like i would say kindergarten and
he we were really close and
he cooks and he i really love to eat
and i love my dad and you know i
actually i'm about to go take a trip up
and go see him so him and my mom got
divorced but what was the best example
of a loving relationship you saw in your
life
the best example of a loving
relationship
i would genuinely say
my relationship right now like
i started seeing this guy
and it's just like you know i don't
really be around a lot of people that
have happy relationships but i made sure
that i wanted to be in a happy
relationship with someone that really
cares about me
and you know like i don't have no
worries about and so i feel like
even though there's not a lot of people
out here that are
healed and acknowledge that and work
towards to be better
i feel like i can make an example of
what it's like to come from something
broken and still be able to find love so
yeah are drugs a part of your life oh i
mean it depends what you mean by drugs
um yeah like i don't do anything crazy
like i definitely am a pothead i smoked
a boat before i came in here
[Laughter]
i don't smoke too much weed like i do it
responsibly
but you know like i'll be on that gas
i'm not even gonna lie
um
i drink a little if that counts um i've
done like i've done some acid
i've done
a little mushrooms i like mushrooms i
don't really [ __ ] with acid like i would
just say i do weed drink a little and
pop a shroom every once in a while you
have to you have to drink in order to
dance
at the club yeah
well i mean not necessarily i mean i i
can smoke see the clubs i go to in miami
we can smoke inside of them so if you're
a pothead go ahead and smoke a plane
yeah but do you have to like be high or
drunk or something just to i can't be
sober period like it's hard like
especially being around these people
that you don't even want to talk to it's
draining like
but you know you want to get turnt
because like you just got to get loose
like
if you sit like sitting still and not
partying nobody wants to be around
someone that's not fun so you just gotta
do what gets you hyped bye guys
are the girls catty with each other
competitive girls
girls definitely do be hand but like i
wish a [ __ ] was up to me like i'm nice
until i'm not so
and they would never say anything to my
face and i feel like i get along with
everybody in the club so if you don't
like me that says something about you
sis you feel me like
so i don't really have problems with
people and i'm a very direct person like
i'm grown so
we're not fun to beat around the bush if
you have a problem with me tell me what
the [ __ ] it is because you're not gonna
[ __ ] up my bag so you've been dancing
now for like two years
yeah how has it changed you
it's made me more confident
um
it definitely changed my type in men for
sure
how has it done that
um because now that i'm around all these
wealthy men why would i ever be with a
man that makes less like to be honest
with you and i actually i didn't even
tell y'all i was in a toxic relationship
at 18 so i lived with my ex and like
this man [ __ ] me over he [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] credit [ __ ] up my
[ __ ] car like he cheated on me
because i was a dancer even though i
financially took care of him but um
i just honestly like being with a man
that makes less than me seeing that
insecurity you know he wasn't secure
enough in himself to feel like i could
be a loyal woman to him so i just feel
like that wouldn't work with you know a
man needs to feel like he
has something to bring to the table so
when he knows he don't got nothing to
bring of course he's gonna be scared and
try you know to lose you because
i made you like the [ __ ] like of course
like
do the other girls get jealous when you
make more money than they do
100
girls copy my swag all the time too
100 like
yeah girls get jealous but i feel like
that's a normal part of life just fix
that like you know catch yourself
wonder why you're jealous he'll like you
can be like me too sis like watch my
youtube channel
like you know you can be just like me or
better if you i mean not not all that
but like if you want to be you should
feel like you're the baddest [ __ ] in
the room that you walk into period y'all
are all great but i feel like i'm the
baddest [ __ ] and you should feel like
you're the baddest pursue tell me about
the difference between
uh the black customers and white
customers oh yeah for sure
okay so
first of all white men i love white men
in the club like now i don't really i
really don't like [ __ ] with white men
like that for real
like not that i've had like a history
with them at all like i've never dated a
white man i'm not even alive
like but like you know i [ __ ] with them
they're cool like you know i [ __ ] with
the white folks like i'm haitian puerto
rican i got a little portuguese in there
so you know i got a little
you know a little gringo in that you
funny and so it's just like um
they're really i think white men are
more respectful to be honest like i'm
sorry like i don't want to be the one to
say it but when i go into the black
clubs all these guys whether their chain
is fake or not they feel entitled as
hell
the way that they talk to you and
dismiss you is just so disrespectful
like you feel the difference
period and i've had seen girls in hood
clubs literally put dollars up their
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and they still didn't throw [ __ ] at them
like these men
you gotta do the most to get a bag out
of them for real like and i'm about to
spend don't waste your time all night
talking to you like a white guy he's he
i've never had a white guy that didn't
like me to be honest but you know i'm
sure they're respectful like you know
i've met guys that have just been like
you know i'm good right now and most of
the time if he tells you that he's good
it's because he likes you he's just
broke you feel me so that's okay like
respectfully you didn't waste my time
and that's moving on to the next
right
and the clubs you work at are there
opportunities in the back rooms to make
more money
i'm sure there is but i don't play that
[ __ ] like nobody ever tells me they do
no i really i genuinely am not a dirty
stripper there are girls that have like
literally came to our table talked to
one of the dudes we were going to all
get a vip one girl dude
[ __ ] the dude in the like bag and then
he didn't want to go up anymore like
[ __ ] will [ __ ] up your bag because
these hoes out here do kind of be they'd
be slimy
i'm not even gonna [ __ ] lie but um
you can't [ __ ] up my bag you feel me
like
and i got the thing is it don't matter
how pretty you are it don't matter how
good you can dance but that really do
help
your finesse game your talk game it's
all about how you say it period in
anything in the world it's about how you
say it so if you know how to talk to a
[ __ ] and [ __ ] and you know how to
seduce
you know
work with your art [ __ ] you win that
[ __ ] you get that [ __ ] some drugs he'd
be straight
period
for real and he had the best night of
his life
do you think you're you think you're
addicted to this fast money
100
yeah yeah
i could not do a job that i make less
that's why i'm doing this music period
that's my way out
until that becomes something better
you'll be doing this
i have plans in the back i don't really
talk too much about my plans because i'm
really big in moving silence and keep on
shocking people
so you know
i definitely have plans to you know you
could say go back to school and get you
know some things but i'm gonna be making
that bag there's no chance of me ever
being broke in my life period is that
the personality trait that helps you
survive in life just here being broke
made me want to have everything
it made me have to work hard is that
what it was just growing up in poverty
kind of
made you
focus on the goal yeah it made me want
to help my peoples and it made me want
to do better for me i just like
everybody [ __ ] on me and hurting me
like i had a lot of people [ __ ] on me
and it's just like it made me want to
[ __ ] on them and so now i am
humbly though you feel me but like
anybody that ever doubted me or treated
me like [ __ ] now they all want to be
part of my life because they see i'm
doing big things now and it's just like
i don't got time for that
what emotions do you go through in your
in your life are you depressed or angry
or
anxious i definitely have a lot of anger
david anger can be channeled into
something positive it sounds like you're
doing that my music yeah 100 percent i
have anger but like i'm i healed from
that stuff you know like
you just you're just feisty oh yeah for
sure but you know it just i'm tired i
don't do [ __ ] you feel me
like i feel like being angry helped me
to stand up for myself because i'm a
snap real [ __ ] quick on you it
used to be i just wait and wait and wait
but nah like my throat chakra elevated
like we not about to play that i'ma tell
you exactly how you made me feel and
that's what it is
i don't give a [ __ ] who you are you're
not gonna disrespect me because one
thing about the stripping game is you
can't ever let the money
like
decide [ __ ] for you you feel me you
gotta have respect for yourself because
if you keep on letting people treat you
like [ __ ] they gonna do that but you
stand up for yourself maybe you get
something different and even if you
don't and they end up firing you or
whatever
don't ever try to force something that
don't work for you because you're always
on your path so if
if that don't work for you it's because
it's time for you to elevate and go
somewhere else where you're gonna make a
bigger bag period like
the money don't run me i don't chase the
bag the bag chased me and that's all it
is tell me about the range of strip
clubs that you've worked in some are
better than others right
i worked in a lot of strip clubs i would
say like
i wouldn't say like hundreds
i say like i worked at the like the best
strip clubs in the area
but like i said like my month span for
working at strip club is like six months
i could don't ever stay longer than sick
but what does a girl need to know if
she's gonna work in these kind of clubs
the management is a challenge right
if you want to be a stripper [ __ ]
you can't be shy you can't be scared of
rejection you can't be scared you can't
be insecure [ __ ] they'll smell right
through that [ __ ] like and if you act
stupid they gonna treat you like you
stupid like [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
about you they're still right out front
of you like
nah you gotta know you gotta be ready
like you gotta be ready like i would say
also don't be afraid to be a [ __ ]
because it's part of your job like
sometimes you gotta get a little [ __ ]
are there nights where you just don't
have it you just can't you can't go out
there what do you mean i mean just
you're not in the mood to to go in front
of a bunch of strange guys and
if i feel that way i'm not going to show
up but usually no i never mess the
weekend of work since i started
stripping damn near my you're gonna lie
that's [ __ ] insane workaholic
uh i work like two to three i don't have
to worry too much about it i like to
make my money and then invest into my
music you know so this makes it work for
me yeah and then to be able to relax and
still work out and just do what i do
yeah you know you can't you can't make
everything about life you got to live
life while it's in the moment it's about
the journey not the destination for uh
what was your favorite memory as a child
my favorite memory as a child
damn
see the thing is i thought about this
too and i was just like all the [ __ ]
that i've been through i feel like it's
[ __ ] up like it's blocked out the good
memories
the best thing as a child like
probably like when i was most at peace i
don't know if i could say like the best
memory when i was most at peace
i remember i was like [ __ ] three and
it's like the first memory i ever had
and it's like my mom and my dad like my
biological father who ain't [ __ ] but
this was before all that [ __ ] happened
and i just remember them standing at the
door and smiling at me and i was in my
room
and then that house went into
foreclosure because my father took all
the money and left us so yeah [ __ ] you
rey
[Laughter]
he hates it he he never wanted me to you
know be anything
be more successful than him he literally
told me that like nobody wanted me so
it's just the fact that i'm that [ __ ]
now
it's just hilarious
let me stop
the internet is going to blow me up
they're going to kill me
the guys that come into the club
yeah i would say about like
80 of the people that are in the club
or 85
are in relationships for sure girls
included like girls wait for their pimps
guys
to pick them up after they like get off
of work
they'd be in the club too watching like
you just state our money on them so then
other people with our money on them you
know what i mean and then they take it
off but the
customers the guys that come in they're
married as well
you're talking about the girls you know
i've heard a lot of stories but i just
feel like
i don't have to work for anybody i don't
want to because i'm an independent
contractor so
if i'm not feeling your energy or i just
don't like your vibe
then i'll go like you know like i'm not
going to bag a dude with a thousand
dollars in his hand to give me money
like
[ __ ] i get paid to hang out with
celebrities do you know how much money
i've made like
and maybe it's just not my [ __ ]
night but most of the time when that
[ __ ] happened another [ __ ] will go
ahead and give me a bigger bag and they
see it and then they get salty like i've
had this happen to me before like
you're not about to play with me i'm
gonna get it back somewhere best believe
that
like what
what regrets do you have
regrets oh let me drink some water
i regret i definitely have regrets
not too many though because
i genuinely like
life happens for a reason everything
happens for a reason like i've been
proven this like
i've talked to angels and everything
like i'm so spiritual
like so i really like
i feel like everything happens for a
reason but i would say my only regret in
life
is that my mother like
because you know she's gone now so it's
like
back when i was younger i i didn't have
no respect for her because like
she was not really she was so bipolar
back and forth she hurt me a lot
and you know i didn't understand what
was going what we were going through
because i was like so young and you know
she
was mentally going through things and
you know having her be disabled and sick
i just really do wish
that like i cherished her more
like we were making amends literally
like on her death bed like the night
that
i was gonna go see her
that's like i was gonna fly to florida
to go see her she literally passed away
so it's just like
i just feel like i really should have
have appreciated my mother more like
regardless of her her illness you know
what i mean
but i was a kid so i don't really hold
it against myself but like i do i do
love her and you know we have a better
relationship now because i'm very
spiritual so
i'd be talking to you know spirits and
stuff
like
i don't even give a [ __ ] like i'm you
know i'm into spiritual healing like i'm
psychic like i help people connect with
people that they love people from past
lives and i'm not afraid or ashamed to
talk about what i believe and that's a
big part of who i am and i really feel
like when i go inside the club
my vibration's so high that i
literally hire everybody else's
vibration in there whether it's having a
dance and having a good time i'm making
somebody's night better and that's
always my goal whether it's with my
music going to the club or anything i do
so period like
tell me about karma
karma karma's real
karma is so real and the funniest thing
is i'm so like
you'll see it happen in your face too or
you'll hear about it in like the
woodworks you know what i mean like
karma's real is how um
i feel like it's all about intention you
know what you're doing and if you don't
know what you're doing you're gonna
learn
but you know at the end of the day like
you got to pay you got to pay up so
don't [ __ ] up like
don't be doing people dirty
and even whatever you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson
a lesson that i've learned
you're a thinker see i have advice but
like a lesson that i've learned i've
been through a lot of [ __ ] though so i
have learned a lot but the best that's
hard like
i'm hard to just [ __ ] y'all like i
haven't been through some [ __ ] so um the
best lesson i've learned in life
really just be grateful
always be grateful for what you have
whether it's nothing
be grateful because that's the only way
you'll ever be happy is if you're just
happy with what you have right there
done in there you never know how bad you
could have it you know what i mean
there's always someone that has the
worst so
i really feel like just be grateful
and save your money save your [ __ ]
money save your money
yeah
excellent yeah eden thank you so much
for sharing your story thank you and
good luck with your music career and
everything else thank you thank you very
much
you did great
thank you i i like a thought
you